Feel that chill?
It's not the end of summer it's the start
of the Halloween season.
Netflix already features a huge lineup of
horror titles primed for a Halloween binge
session, but the service is also loading up
on brand new horror.
Here are the scariest new releases hitting
Netflix this October.
Creeped Out: Season 1
This horror-themed coproduction between Netflix
and the BBC may come across as a Black Mirror
for kids, but...well, okay, on second thought,
that's exactly what this is.
As an anthology series, each episode tells
its own bite-sized horror story with different
characters and different settings.
The twist is that all the stories are connected
by a creepy, masked man who's out to "collect"
mankind's darkest tales.
The episodes explore everything from psychological
horror to the supernatural, preying on your
darkest fears and giving you plenty of reasons
to sleep with the lights on.
The first season of Creeped Out debuted on
BBC in 2017, but October 4th will mark the
first time the series is available for an
international audience.
Malevolent
Here's an interesting twist on the haunted
house genre.
Malevolent follows a brother-and-sister scam
artist duo who trick people into thinking
their houses are haunted, then go in and pretend
to drive the ghosts away.
Business is booming until they run into an
actual haunted house and discover that real
ghosts are a lot more dangerous than the fake
ones.
Look for it on October 5th.
Apostle
Gareth Evans is best known in the film world
for writing and directing the action-packed
martial arts film The Raid and its sequel,
The Raid 2.
But with Apostle, Evans is making a departure
from his usual action fare and taking a deep
dive into cult-based horror.
At the turn of the 20th century, a sadistic
cult kidnaps a young woman and takes her to
their remote island for, uh, culty purposes.
What they didn't count on was the woman's
brother coming after her.
If the trailer is any indication, that's just
the start of the mayhem you can expect from
Apostle.
Strap in on October 12th.
The Haunting of Hill House: Season 1
Get ready for all the horror you can stomach
with The Haunting of Hill House.
Based on the classic novel by Shirley Jackson,
the series stars Carla Gugino and Michiel
Huisman and centers on a family that comes
back to the haunted house where they grew
up.
The Haunting of Hill House comes from Mike
Flanagan, who's recently been making waves
in the horror world with Netflix's Gerald's
Game and his under-the-radar horror gems Oculus
and Hush.
Look for the first season of The Haunting
of Hill House to hit Netflix on October 12th.
Haunted: Season 1
If fiction isn't your speed this Halloween,
fear not!
Netflix is also bringing in a horror series
based on true events.
Well, sort of.
Haunted sits down with people who claim to
have first-hand accounts of paranormal experiences.
Ghosts, aliens, monsters in the night it's
all in here, and the series will recreate
those stories in terrifying detail, fleshing
out the horror in imaginative new ways.
Part true terror and part cinematic creepfest,
Haunted is bound to offer plenty of reasons
to sit in front of the TV all day.
Tune in when Season 1 drops on October 19th.
The Chilling Adventures of Sabrina
Maybe you want a horror-tinged version of
the late '90s sitcom Sabrina the Teenage Witch,
or maybe you dig those teenaged horndogs on
Riverdale, but you want more pacts with the
devil.
Well good news: The Chilling Adventures of
Sabrina puts the classic Archie comics character
smack dab in the middle of a battle against
evil.
According to Entertainment Weekly, The Chilling
Adventures of Sabrina was originally meant
to act as a sister series to Riverdale.
Once production moved over to Netflix, however,
the idea of bridging the two shows was put
on the back burner.
It's still possible, but for now, The Chilling
Adventures of Sabrina stands completely on
its own.
Take a look when it arrives on October 26th.
Castlevania: Season 2
The first season of Netflix's hyper-violent
Castlevania adaptation came out of the gates
with middling reviews, but quickly built up
a large fan following.
The story follows Trevor Belmont, the protagonist
of Castlevania III: Dracula's Curse, as he
battles the supernatural forces of Dracula.
"Trevor, join us. Sure, by the way you're all going to
die."
By all accounts, Season 2 will pick up right
where the first season left off, drawing viewers
further into the horrifying world of 15th-century
Wallachia.
With horror and action in equal measure, Castlevania
makes the perfect show to binge this Halloween
season.
If you haven't caught the first season yet,
you'll have plenty of time to catch up before
Season 2 lands on October 26th.
New Thriller Movies
While Netflix will be putting out their usual
selection of films and shows from all genres,
Halloween calls for a special focus on the
horror-based titles.
From horror-classic The Shining arriving on
the 1st to The Exorcism of Molly Hartley,
which hits Netflix on the 4th, there's a lot
of new stuff on the way.
And while they aren't pure horror, Stephen
King's supernatural drama The Green Mile and
the first two films in the Blade trilogy and
also arrive on the 1st.
What better time than Halloween to relive
those classics?
"Some motherf------ always trying to iceskate
uphill."
Oh, Blade.
We missed you.